this episode brought to you by Stardust
fan sharing video reactions to movies TV
and trailers also brought to you by the
black tux
premium rental suits and tuxedos
delivered
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to you
know I pick on this guy a lot don't get
me wrong a lot of Adam Sandler films are
awful to sit coming across as lazy
unfunny and even annoying but I forget
sometimes that this is a mad talented
person his songs can be great his
unexpected delivery can get a huge laugh
even dramatically he can not only be
good he can be really good sometimes we
let the worst of someone's work
overshadow the good and Adam Sandler
does have a healthy amount of good work
he's left behind that's why I'm gonna
give credit where credit's due and count
down his top 11 best films I see I don't
think I can make it to top 11 Kenya but
you know what I'm gonna show you they
don't have to be masterpieces they don't
have to be ground breakers they just
have to be worth the ticket feed to see
them on the big screen and you know what
not only do I believe there's 11 I
believe there can be even more in the
future please tell us like please don't
suck please don't suck please don't suck
so without further ado I'm paying
tribute to a flawed but still talented
performer this is the top 11 best Adam
Sandler movies
[Music]
[Applause]
numberless airheads hey like I said they
don't all have to be masterpieces this
is a cute comedy with a lot of character
actors that were soon gonna be big stars
including Sandler Brendan Fraser and
Steve Buscemi the three of them played
band members of a group called the lone
Ranger's the name alone is already a
beautifully stupid contradiction trying
over and over to get their band heard
they end up taking over the local radio
station holding it hostage only to have
their cassette of their music beat
destroyed before playing it so shit
they're stuck there for no reason not
knowing what to do but the attention
gets a lot of headbanger fans to
surround the building saying fight the
establishment all of it trying to figure
out how the hell to get out of there a
simple idea with simple jobs but they're
still effective the actors all have a
dim-witted charm to them the commentary
is obvious but still clever and the last
while not nice flappers do still get
plenty of chocolates it's honestly a
totally fine movie satirizing Fame and
media attention but this time with the
heavy metal world
it's totally serviceable not a glowing
endorsement but if somebody asked if I'd
recommend it I'd say sure like I said
not a glowing endorsement but a decent
way
[Music]
number two you don't mess with the Zohan
this movie is just the right amount of
silly from visual jokes to funny actors
to a downright bizarre premise Sandler
plays an Israeli army commando who takes
down terrorists but is sick of his way
of life he fakes his own death so he can
follow his real dream which is
hairdresser yep he becomes a stylist in
New York and is apparently really good
at it he even has the skills to take
care of critics who are either too harsh
on him or his customers here comes the
double foot manly smelly smelly not
taken of course when the bad guys find
out he's still alive they try to hunt
him down and obviously hilarity ensues
oh and I don't mean that sarcastically I
think this film is legitimately
hilarious it was written by Judd Apatow
and Robert Smigel courage the insult
comic dog it's totally in bad taste from
beginning to end and doesn't give a shit
about it at all mostly because it knows
it's a dumb silly comedy but it has a
ton of fun with it the humor ranges from
weird to really weird there is something
so zany and over-the-top about this
movie that even when a joke doesn't work
it's so surreal you can't help but still
kind of giggle at it
elbow is going on this is one of those
films that got panned by critics but in
my opinion still brings the laughs it's
idiotic and won't further anyone's
understanding of the world but screw it
it's just for a good funny and that's
enough for me
number not reign over me this is one of
those Sandlin movies that flew under the
radar well certainly on even most people
agree this film has difficult emotions
being tackled and a resolution that's
not always clear and easy to understand
Sandler plays Charlie a man who lost his
family in 9/11 and shuts himself off
from the world his college roommate
played by Don Cheadle meets him by
chance and sees how far he slipped from
reality
he tries befriending him to make things
better discovering that things in his
life or and always that great either the
more time they spend with one another
the more they find they're both making
things better and worse for the other
the film got mixed reviews when it came
out which is not surprising as the movie
is kind of a mixed bag it does sometimes
feel forced and a little off but the
reviews were still mostly positive I
think that's what you can call it mostly
positive even people who didn't like it
had to admit there were still strong
moments from Bushido and Sandler giving
an interesting and troubled look at two
lives who are laws for two very
different reasons I see the problems
with it but I still think the good stuff
is too good overlooked for the number of
times it plays it safe there's just as
many times it takes a risk if anything
else it's good acting from a good cast
proving once again Sandler can hold his
own even against it I'm at greats like
Sheila if he haven't already take a look
it's worth it in the end
[Music]
number eight the mayor wit stories new
and selected this Netflix movie came out
in 2017 and had quite the cast including
Sandler Ben Stiller Emma Thompson and
Dustin Hoffman the film centers around
the mayor wits dysfunctional family and
how the extremely eccentric father
played by Hoffman affected the lives of
his kids played by Sandler and Stiller
and that's really about it what a
character study than a plot driven movie
but these characters are interesting and
how flawed they are Stiller is a
successful businessman who hates
everything his father stands for while
Sandler is more loving towards his dad
but it's also very lost emotionally and
financially the two of them butt heads a
lot throughout the film and they're both
phenomenal Stiller gives a gut-wrenching
speech near the end and Sandler is so
natural and believable it doesn't even
feel like a performance it just feels
like you're watching the troubles of a
real guy the film itself can get a
little grating due to Hoffman as the
father but to be fair that's kind of the
point and I'd be lying if I said I was
totally satisfied to what it all amounts
to but it's still reasonably well-done
and feels very real particularly with
the performances in my opinion I think
it might even be Sandler's best acting I
never once felt like he was lying or
acting it felt 100% real it's a unique
film with some unique talent giving us
some unique characters
[Music]
number six 50 first dates well it does
have a lot of groaner moments and
awkward jokes the comedy romance and
ideas that do work in the film far
overpower the ones that don't it's just
a clever idea that surprisingly leads to
some likable chemistry Sandler plays a
veterinarian who falls in love with the
seemingly charming woman played by Drew
Barrymore the next day however she
completely forgets who he is why well
she has short-term memory loss so her
recollections only go as far as 24 hours
so every time Sandler sees her he has to
either tell her who he is or even more
awkwardly come up with different ways
for them to meet each time her family
wants him out the picture though as they
like not having to tell her every day
about her condition
saving her the emotional stress Sandler
can't help but still feel something for
this prison though despite the fact that
she keeps forgetting who we use the
chemistry between Sandler and Barrymore
is adorable believable and yes even
funny she does a great job selling that
she's never seen Sandler before over and
over and over
this could get old very fast but she
brings both the comedy and the humanity
to it on top of that Sandler coming up
with new ways to try and explain or even
trick her into going out with him that
only shows his comedic side but also how
much he cares about wanting to be with
her I especially like the ending which
not to give anything away but they don't
just cure the illness they do have to
acknowledge the problem for the rest of
their lives most comedies like this
would have the problem solved by the end
but they go that extra mile and trying
to be both delicate and creative in
living with the disorder
it's a crazy romance that surprisingly
have just as much heart as farts - I
really just make that joke
[Music]
now listen the weddings
so yeah the 80s are everywhere now
everybody reference it it's practically
become a cliche but Sandler was one of
the earliest people to poke fun at it
waiting only eight years to understand
what made it stand out compared to
modern day he plays a wedding singer
who's jilted at the altar and starts
turning into an angry bitter drunk by
the waitress play by Drew Barrymore
seems to help turn things around the
only downside is she's marrying a
gherkin yeah you know where this is
going
it's every 80s romantic comedy that
while following some cliches too close
to the letter like having the fiance be
an unfunny jerk still manages to work
with it okay because well it is a satire
of the 80s was that intentional probably
not but it works the same way demolition
man is perfectly representing the 90s
without even knowing it the company gets
a lot of laughs I think everybody who
watched this movie has Minds they quote
from it things that could have been
brought to my attention yesterday do you
have any experience I'm a big fan of
money I like it I use it I have a little
losing his mind I'm reaping all the
benefits and once again the romance is
very sweet very more in Sandler had
great chemistry and this is where it all
started yes manipulative and contrived
but it's the same way shitty Christmas
rom-coms are now you kind of accept how
stupid they are and have fun with and
seeing how this is a throwback to the
80s doesn't it kind of make sense it's a
lot of fun with just enough heart to
make it this is a predictable yet
enjoyable film that still lasts long
after the eighth
[Music]
hey guys here's the best reactions to
what I just reviewed this week Adam
Sandler is pretty much the Michael Bay
of comedy I mean he's a lazy hack now
pandering to the lowest common
denominator but there was a time in the
90s when he was good this is a perfect
example of that this and Billy Madison
are still definitely my two favorite
Adam Sandler movies this movie so funny
from start to finish a great sports
comedy you have to see it if you have it
no matter where you come from we can all
agree shooter McGavin is one of the best
villains put the cinema I can name the
amount of movies that have made me cry
actual tears on two hands Adam Sandler's
click is one of those movies what really
amazes me about click is it actually got
an emotional reaction out of me there's
a lot of good dramatic moments yeah it's
good commentary how we tend to
fast-forward through life I know it's
got the typical Adam Sandler stupid here
but it's definitely worth checking out
you have opinions a lot of opinions
about movies TV shows even trailers
there's so much to talk about you get
emotional about them just like anybody
gets emotional about them well now you
don't have to wait to get that raw
emotion straight to the Internet why
because we got star does app it allows
you instantly to film your reactions to
movies TV shows and even trailers happy
angry confused whatever it is and
whatever your reaction is Stardust is
there to show it some of the wildest and
craziest reactions are on there and
there's so much fun to watch there's a
lot of variety endless possibilities and
they're definitely worth checking out
I even using myself this weekend look at
the trailers for Teen Titans go to the
movies game over man and one of my
favorite Sandler films Hotel
Transylvania it's there to get the first
and best reaction that you got it's a
ton of fun and 100 percent free so check
out other people's opinions as well as
sharing your own there's a lot of fun to
be had so go ahead and see what you're
missing out on
look at that suit that is a nice suit a
coat that's never been button a tie
that's been tied once so he can just
keep reusing it over and over and over
okay maybe then this now a great suit
isn't anything special but when I do
want a good suit for special events I go
to the black tux calm I mean everyone
wants to look good for that special
event but they don't want to fork out a
ton of money for it either
well the black tux calm is your answer
with high quality rental suits and
tuxedos delivered to your doorstep
it's such an easy way to rent suits and
tuxes online most suits go for something
like 1,200 bucks but at the black tux
they start at $95 they let you create
your own look and choose from a ton of
great stylist their expert customer care
has your back every step of the way and
it's completely done online you can even
do a free home try on so you can see the
fit and feel the quality of your soup
months before your big event and after
ordering your suit they'll have it to
you 14 days before the event even starts
and if anything is less than perfect the
black tux will send you a free
replacement right away when your event
is over you just drop your rental back
in the mail and shipping is free both
ways and hey you want to get 20 bucks
off your purchase just visit the black
tux calm slash nostalgia critic
that's right just go to the black tux
consolation nostalgia Creek and you'll
get $20 right off your purchase look
good look smooth just look a little
better than I do
hey I'm rocking that hat though visit
the black tux comm premium rental suits
and tuxedos delivered
you
another fuck happy gilmore yeah it's
stupid
yeah it's immature yeah it's every dumb
sports movie cliche in the world but
it's funny
Sandler plays a hockey player named
happy well unfortunately sucks at what
he does but when he discovers he has a
great arm for golf suddenly he realizes
he can make enough money to save his
grandmother's house because of course
there's a grandmother's house but the
nasty mean bully because of course
there's a nasty mean boy what's to stop
him from stealing the spotlight as well
as his hot girlfriend who's in love with
him because of course there's a hot
girlfriend who's in love with him again
this is not a particularly story based
comedy the focus is on Sandler's
attitude and the attitude of the people
around him as phoned-in as these
characters are written they're played by
very funny people angry nurse at the old
folks home is played by a hilarious Ben
Stiller Pollak read himself Carl
Weathers plays a great bitter coach and
Christopher McDonald might play one of
the funniest bullies in sports film
history
well moron good for happy gilmore my god
this is such a throwaway role but he
adds a delivery and energy that makes
him a comedic foil who's just as much
fun as the comedic leaves eight pieces
of shit like you for breakfast
you read pieces of shit for breakfast no
the funniest cameo of Bob Barker ever a
beautifully long list of completely
meaningless deaths and enough lines to
quote for years to come why didn't you
just go home that's your home are you
too good for your home happy gilmore is
just a fun dumb flick as the typical
Adam Sandler movie formula goes this one
arguably did it the funniest the price
is wrong bitch
punch-drunk love though a big hit with
critics audiences seem to either love or
hate this film personally I think it's
so strange so mysterious and so well
acted that I can't help but love it even
though I'll be the first to admit I have
no idea what it means
Sandler plays a man named Barry a quiet
awkward reserved yet totally impulsive
al Kass who's emotionally abused by his
sisters as being scammed and robbed by a
call girl service as things get stranger
and stranger a kind of woman named
Elizabeth played by Emily Watson enters
his life and finally starts to give it
purpose from there just weirdness all
sorts of weirdness this was written and
directed by Paul Thomas Anderson the
same guy who did Magnolia Boogie Nights
and there will be blood so that gives
you an idea of the strange arthouse
nature that lies ahead with this film
what's the point of it why does it exist
why is everything in it so odd and
unexplainable I don't know but it draws
you into where you kind of are okay with
not knowing between Sandler is brilliant
acting the surreal atmosphere and just
downright bizarre method of storytelling
it truly is a one-of-a-kind film you're
either gonna get into or you're not
personally I loved every minute of it
and a lot of that does come from Sam vu
who carries a lot of this film with his
performance it's a totally out there
experience but still has me fascinated
every time I see it
[Music]
[Applause]
number three number two Hotel
Transylvania and Hotel Transylvania 2
yeah you might as well want these two
together the Hotel Transylvania movies
are beautifully animated extremely funny
incredibly charming hugely creative and
carry a surprising amount of heart every
release gets trashed by critics and I
still don't understand why they're great
for kids great for adults wonderfully
written and wonderfully voiced with
Sandler almost unrecognizable as Dracula
in a world terrified of monsters Sandler
as Dracula built a hotel for all the
famous Halloween freaks to come and
relax his daughter may miss though is
growing restless and wants to see the
world Dracula is too afraid of what will
happen to her though due to what
happened to his wife who was killed by
an angry mob but when a young traveler
visits telling her the world isn't what
she thinks it is a drift builds between
the two of them and the musters
witnessed the real scares with the
horrors of parenting these films were
directed by ginn dieter Tokarski the
creator of Samurai Jack and they have
his stamp all over them they're fast
they're energized that brilliantly
designed they throw a ton of various
jokes at you and they surprisingly can
be very moving both films are fantastic
at portraying very relatable family
problems while also getting tons of last
based off of these hilarious characters
these movies are becoming new staples of
Halloween you just look at them and you
get excited for the holiday which is
strange seeing how the third one is
coming out in summer but I guess we can
buy it around Halloween hopefully it's
as good as the other two because these
films are incredibly funny as well as
heartwarming despite what critics say
this is a series of movies I predict are
going to get more and more popular with
every passing Halloween season
[Music]
and number one best Adam Sandler movie
is funny people here Mia funny people
got mixed reviews when it was released
and most audiences left not really
enjoying it all that much but under this
seemingly pointless story lies an
interesting subtext if you connect it to
Sandler's life which you could argue the
movie was doing already Sandler plays a
comedic movie star named George Simmons
but let's be honest he's playing Adam
Sandler he used to be a stand-up turned
into a movie star and his film seemed
like quickly turned out fluff that
somehow make a lot of money he gives a
shock though when he discovers he has
leukemia thinking his days are numbered
he goes back to stand-up where he meets
a writer played by Seth Rogen who also
does stand-up the two of them form a
friendship despite the fact that Saylor
doesn't always treat him that great but
he's dying what can you do well suddenly
halfway through the movie is leukemia is
cured yeah complete recovery and
everything so where does the film go now
well that's the same question the
characters ask now that Sandler is
better he feels he can still be a dick
and ignore all the mental pain he was
confronting but Rogen tells him it isn't
and shouldn't be as easy as all that but
to go back and forth between respecting
each other and hating each other
ultimately resulting in an ending that
honestly doesn't resolve that much if
anything it indicates that much of these
actions will be repeated in the future
and the change is made if any are very
minimal so this is kind of really
friggin interesting the comedy is decent
and the acting from everyone is once
again great but really think about it if
this character is supposed to be Sandler
why do half of these choices happen
we've seen films like top 5 or loss in
translation or eight-mile where we know
they're semi-autobiographical around the
person claim so why would Sandler heaven
so be such a jerk a jerk who's dying no
less Sandler is said to be one of the
sweetest celebrities in Hollywood yet he
portrays himself as a lost asshole who
rarely learns his lesson why would the
film be so similar to his life in other
ass
but not here the short answer is I don't
know but it's interesting to think about
isn't it the same way the Rocky movies
kind of reflected Stallone's career the
underdog becoming a star turning into a
joke than balancing out in as old age
the same way we might see kind of a
reflection here Sandler's comedies even
he acknowledges sometimes have little to
no substance even says sometimes they're
done just so he can vacation somewhere
yet he still makes them that way while
also trying more experimental rules
could it be this is how he sees himself
as somebody who is successful in some
ways but lost in others is it an
exaggeration of what he thinks he could
become has-been or currently is maybe
it's a cautionary tale for not just
others but himself as well like I said
this is speculation I have nothing to
back this up but why have the
character's career be so eerily similar
like any intriguing piece of art I don't
always know what the artists intent is
but what it reflects is even more
fascinating the film is such a strange
blur of fact and fiction that you can't
always pinpoint what's supposed to be
real and what isn't it's the only didn't
play him in this movie the film wouldn't
be as relevant but he does why why pick
a role so seemingly similar to him and
yet in many other respects so seemingly
the opposite it's a question I don't
know if I'll ever fully give the answer
to but it's also a question I don't
fully need the answer to or even what
the mystery of it is far more engaging
it's like a Rorschach test of how much
of the actor in his career you see in
the role and it can be a surprisingly
compelling take given your point of view
I can't act like I know this was the
intention but the ideas are planted and
they're worth talking about in a weird
way this Sandler movie more than any
other asks the most questions it makes
you think the most and given the actors
background of movies the one that makes
you think the most is the one I'm gonna
put as number one n
funny people is a fascinating reflection
we just don't always know of exactly
what
[Music]
not the Nostalgia Critic I remember so
you don't have to look at 2:11 huh
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys here's even more reactions to
what I just reviewed this week I think
this one has one of the dumbest setups
of all time I mean it's filled with plot
holes and it's kind of silly but it's so
charming and so cute that I actually
can't hate it this is definitely one of
my favorite Adam Sandler movies it's
funny
it has great music it actually has Adam
Sandler being funny which is rare
nowadays this is what makes me laugh the
most I quote it million times with my
family we all know this film it still
makes me laugh to say it's touching it's
heartwarming you have no idea how good
to see the Adam Sandler actually you've
acted in a good movie in the 2010
Sandler does an amazing job which is
shows that when he actually acts he's
actually a really good actor Stardust is
a fun way to share your thoughts right
away without having to wait a ton of
people have so many ways to share their
thoughts and you can be one of those
unique voices whether it's extreme love
extreme hate subtle analysis or even a
one word reaction Stardust is there to
make sure your voice is heard and shared
with a ton of people we absolutely love
going through and seeing everybody's
different reactions the over-the-top
one's the funny ones there's such a wide
variety out there and we love watching
them and you will too so download the
app get out there and show us your crazy
reactions
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shat on this week we are doing Cedars
foster care it is the mission of Cedars
to help children who have been abused
neglected and homeless achieves safety
stability and enduring family
relationships founded in 1947 Cedars
continues their vision today to create a
place where children can experience a
real childhood and begin planning for
the future that simple act of kindness
over 70 years ago has resulted in
thousands of children building new
family lives offering young people safe
shelter and the skills to adapt to a
quickly changing world today's reality
is harsh and not every home today is
safe for every child poverty drug use
mental illness criminal activity and
neglect place children at extreme risk
Cedars continues to respond giving hope
to youth in need and direction to
families struggling to stay together if
you look at their site in their YouTube
page you can witness all the wonderful
people they bring together in all the
positive ways they help check them out
and see if you can play a big part in a
child's future
[Laughter]
you